[Music]
brave is one of our favorite films and
Merida is one of our favorite Disney
Princesses but did you know just what
might have influenced the movie stay
tuned to the end when we'll tell you
about what life was really like in
medieval Scotland if this is your first
time visiting the things then give this
video a like and hit the subscribe
button today we are going to tell you
the disturbing real story behind
Disney's brave bears something that
plays a big part in brave is the
character of more give a dangerous and
demonic bear but were you wondering if
there ever were bears in Scotland well
the answer to that question is yes
Scotland was home to bears quite
possibly up until around the 11th
century AD which is a little after the
story of brave is set the existence of
Scottish bears is something that the
Roman poet Marshall wrote about in the
year 80 AD
he told of how a Caledonian the Latin
word for Scottish bear was brought to
Rome to take place in the games there
and legend has it that in 1050 a member
of the clan Gordon was ordered to put
three bears heads on his coat of arms
because he had killed one however it has
been argued that that is the result of
an incorrect translation and it should
be boars heads but anyway the only place
in Scotland where you'll see bears right
now is in one of the country's zoos
however that could all change
Scottish landowner Paul Lister has
announced plans to reintroduce wild
brown bears to his 23,000 square foot
estate in the country of Sutherland so
while his plans are still very much a
work in progress
bears could be another once extinct
species of animal reintroduced to the
British Isles tartan one thing that you
can't help but notice in brave is the
sheer amount of tartan on display this
checkered plaid pattern is associated
with Scotland and Scottish clans in fact
every clan has its own tartan that's
true to the extent that Disney ended up
feeling the design of the Clan dunbroch
tartan with the Scottish Government's
Scottish Register of Tartans however a
lot of the official Tartans are
relatively recent when King George the
fourth visited Edinburgh in 1822 he was
the first reigning British monarch to
visit Scotland since Charles the second
100
fifty years earlier so his visit was a
big thing and the event was organized by
the renowned author Sir Walter Scott now
Sir Walter had become famous for his
romantic literature about the Scottish
Highlands and decided to create a
pageant involving pipers and a lot of
tartan but here's the thing the
traditional Tartans had more or less
died out by them so new ones had to be
created this is why many of the Tartans
that are seen today in pageants actually
date from less than 200 years ago
incidentally people who do not belong to
an ancient Scottish clan are allowed to
wear tartan on one condition if they are
a subject of Her Majesty Queen Elizabeth
the second it is custom that they are
allowed to wear the royal Stuart tartan
which was of course created by Sir
Walter Scott medieval Scottish royal
women when Disney and Pixar created
brave they introduced us to a new member
of the pantheon of Disney princesses
that was Merida the feisty redhead bow
and arrow shooting princess who the
movie is all about however while
Meredith's story is ultimately a happy
one that wasn't the case for all
medieval Scottish royal women one sad
story is that of Queen Margaret also
known as the maid of Norway Margaret was
the granddaughter of King Alexander the
third of Scotland and the daughter of
his daughter Margaret who was married to
King Eric ii of norway
however the older Margaret died in
childbirth and with all Alexander's
children also having died the baby
Margaret was heir to the Scottish throne
however Alex remarried and his new wife
was pregnant with an heir when tragedy
struck the King's horse fell off a cliff
in a storm killing him and sadly his
widow miscarried meaning that Margaret
who was just three years old became
Queen and in 1290 on her way to Scotland
she died aged just seven leaving
Scotland facing civil war another famous
Scottish royal woman from that time was
GRU ik not heard of her while she was
married to Scotland's King Macbeth
making her the real version of the
villainous Lady Macbeth from
Shakespeare's play however the real
Macbeth was a devout and good King and
we don't think his wife the
granddaughter of Kenneth the third of
Scotland was really anything as bad as
the fictional version tough Scottish
women although some of the Royal
Scottish women of the Middle Ages were
somewhat hard done by people looking for
a real-life model for Merida have some
pretty good exam
to choose from the ranks of Scotland's
nobility one of our favorite stories is
that of Agnes Countess of Dunbar in 1388
Scotland and England were at war which
was pretty common throughout a lot of
the Middle Ages and they laid siege to
Dunbar castle while her husband was away
fighting Agnes was left in charge of the
servants and a small number of gars
while the attacking army was expected to
take the castle pretty quickly
Agnes held out every day she and her
servants would walk the ramparts and
dust down the damage some work but that
wasn't all they did they dropped
boulders lobbed into the castle on the
attackers battering ram and they held
strong for five months until King Edward
the third of England ordered the siege
to end there was also Euphemia Countess
of Ross she was twice widowed and when
she asked Alexander Mackenzie to become
her third husband and he rejected her
she had him thrown into prison quite
clearly not a woman to be messed around
with then so we think that those are
things that could potentially have
served as a bit of an inspiration for
brave medieval Scottish life when you're
watching brave it might look like living
in medieval Scotland is a fun thing
however the reality of the situation is
that it wasn't even if you were wealthy
things weren't all that good there was a
low life expectancy and many women died
while giving birth and if you were poor
then things were even worse for instance
a typical meal for a peasant would be
bread porridge and oat cakes if you were
lucky you might be able to eat some
mutton things were admittedly a lot
better if you're a royal or noble it
wasn't uncommon to see meats such as
Swan or seal at a big feast that said
one of the interesting things about
brave is the way it isn't entirely
historically accurate although it is set
in the 10th century people are seen
wearing corsets which weren't invented
until the 15th century
but what's worth pointing out is that
the story is an original and it is
inspired by many things ranging from
writer Brenda Chapman's relationship
with her daughter as well as the fairy
tales of Hans Christian Andersen in the
Brothers Grimm so maybe we shouldn't be
too harsh about the historical accuracy
of the movie but what do you think about
brave did you like it
what were the bits that you liked best
and what would you change about it don't
be shy tell us in the comments and
that's all for the disturbing real story
behind Disney's brave thanks for
watching and don't forget
get to subscribe
[Music]